by now you've probably seen footage of
Elon musk's remarks at the New York
Times dealbook Summit last night this is
an annual Summit that brings together
Business Leaders and uh several of them
are interviewed on stage now normally
it's not very newsworthy certainly not
anything that I would pay attention to
or you would probably pay attention to
anytime you gather together a bunch of
corporate CEOs and business owners you
typically typically get a lot of
carefully choreographed language it's
all very brand safe by Design um nothing
interesting is happening sort of
designed so that nothing interesting
will happen but this year's dealbook
Summit was unique mainly because of this
one moment it came during uh Elon musk's
interview with CNBC host Andrew Ross
sorin sorin began by asking musk about
the ongoing Advertiser boycott of uh of
X formerly known as Twitter and weather
musk is desperate to win those
advertisers back and he was certainly
expecting to hear some kind of response
about what musk is going to do to get
those advertisers to come back but
instead here's what musk uh said in
response watch and you're clarifying
this
now um but there's a public perception
that that was part of a apology tour if
you will that this had been said online
there was all of the criticism there was
advertisers leaving we talked to Bob
Iger I hope they stop you hope don't
advertise you don't want them to
advertise no what do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go
yourself but go
yourself is that
clear I hope it is hey Bob if you're in
the audience well well let me ask you
then that's how I feel don't
advertise now there's more to that clip
which we'll play in a little bit but for
now
what you just heard is Elon Musk telling
the CEO of Disney and many other uh CEOs
in no uncertain terms to go f themselves
and uh as far as Bob Iger CEO of Disney
goes this is the head of you know one of
the most powerful entertainment
companies on the planet and Bob Iger was
apparently in the audience when musk
said that which is awesome but musk
wasn't just talking to him of course he
was delivering the same message to every
other corporate Advertiser that has
suspended advertising on AIS way to uh
force him to restore the old censorship
regime of Twitter and as of now the list
of advertisers boycotting the platform
includes more than a 100 companies
including some of the largest
corporations on the planet and musk was
telling all of these corporations which
are now clearly trying to destroy him
for political reasons uh to go to hell
now it goes without saying that nothing
like this has uh really happened before
especially not at a summit like that and
that's why Andrew Ross sorin the
journalist on stage with him was
completely uh shell shocked he could
barely get a word out in the business
world what musk did is like Unthinkable
the owners of major corporations aren't
exactly known for standing on principle
even when that principle could destroy
the business model of their entire
company it doesn't happen very often
that's what Elon mus did and also
mainstream journalists like sorin
certainly cannot conceive of anyone
actually standing up to corporations
like Disney because these are all
subservient masochistic little weaklings
who bow to our corporate Overlord Lords
every day and they are shocked to see
anybody do otherwise at the same time
what was even more interesting than
musk's remarks and what ultimately
proved his point was how the corporate
news media responded to what musk said
they were universally outraged they
didn't even try to hide their disdain
even though musk was not addressing them
specifically but they were offended on
behalf of all the corporate advertisers
the dear poor corporate advertisers that
were just insulted in this way that's
kind of odd when you think about it uh
or at least it should be odd after all
these media Outlets claim to be
interested in reporting the news they
claim that they're not simply mess
vessels for corporate messaging that's
what they claim but last night they
couldn't help themselves one after
another these Outlets unloaded on Elon
Musk in the most disparaging possible
terms it was clearly personal for them
watch just moments ago tonight Elon Musk
in an interview with Andrew Ross sorin
at the New York Times dealbook Summit
saying this to advertisers who've left X
over his endorsement of anti-Semitic
content if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go
yourself but go
yourself is that
clear I hope it
is seems pretty clear out front now Dana
Hall Bloomberg senior reporter who
covers Elon Musk so Dana the New York
Times uh reporting that this
anti-semitic post could possibly cost X
up to $75 million in Lost ad Revenue
this year at meantime musk is warning
that the advertising boycott could kill
the company he's not happy about it it's
fascinating for him to say that of
course based on why the boycott happened
now a number of advertisers have fled
Twitter recently not just Disney but
also Paramount NBC Universal Comcast
Lionsgate Warner Brothers Discovery and
a host of others nobody wants to be
around this toxic landscape at the
moment and now you have musk stepping up
with this it's just a phenomenal thing
for him to say considering that
advertising represents the bulk of
Twitter's Revenue still moreover musk's
plan is to move away from all of that
revenue and try and get into more of a
subscription model in which he'd have an
everything app yeah like people are
going to trust him now and moreover
people would pay regular fees for
different Services yeah like people are
going to give them their credit card
numbers at this point you've got to
wonder what he was thinking Caleb silver
and this is so interesting because this
is one of the first times that musk has
very directly taken on this issue that
has built and built over the last
several weeks about these advertisers
these big companies these big
corporations saying wait a second I
don't want my content next to this
anti-semitic stuff that musk has allowed
to be on the platform yeah and if you
listen to the entire quote from that
that dealbook interview he said that
several times go after yourself several
times and then he said hi Bob we could
only assume he was talking to Bob Iger
Bob head of Disney the head of Disney
which was one of the big advertisers
that pulled but you mention other
advertisers we're talking about some of
the biggest advertisers out there
including Comcast the parent company of
this network Warner Brothers Apple
Coca-Cola others have pulled their ads
and he also said in that interview with
Andrew Ross sorin I wish they would stop
I wish they would stop advertising and
then he dropped the f bomb so clearly
putting his finger in the eye of the
people that pay the bills to run X which
is an advertising delivery mechanism or
was until he bought it and now we don't
know really what he's trying to do with
it at the end of the clip there's a
disclosure that Elon Musk was calling
out Comcast at the dealbook summit and
Comcast incidentally is the parent
company of NBC Universal and then NBC
News just so happens to accuse Elon Musk
of hating Jewish people and then there's
the uh derang segment from KTLA in Los
Angeles the flagship station of the CW
television network in which the analyst
explains that no one will ever trust
Elon Musk again because such a he's such
a a horrible person he's created a toxic
landscape they even suggest that musk is
going to try and steal customers credit
card numbers because he told off Bob
Iger so not just attacking him for what
he said they're saying preemptively that
if he pivots X to a subscription model
that um you shouldn't trust him because
he's going to rip you off and this kind
of demented coverage has been Relentless
it's been coming from every single
corporate media Outlet Fox News accused
musk of anti-semitism
last week for example just a couple days
ago ABC News uh ran a segment in which
the anchor and panelist took turns
trashing Elon Musk and the platform and
the segment ended with ABC News urging
the White House as well as everyone in
the ABC News audience to abandon the
platform they could not have been more
explicit about their activism watch now
musk facing some backlash here after he
called a post on X repeating a common
conspiracy theory about Jewish people
Musk called it the actual truth and then
that post prompted some major
advertisers to pause their ads on X and
also today the mayor of Paris deciding
to quit the platform which she called a
gigantic Global sewer so let's bring
back our panel yes you have freedom of
speech but there are consequences for
your freedom of speech when your freedom
of speech causes harm and what we saw
was that today when we know to when he
landed uh he said a quote on X where he
says quote action speaks louder than
words for me this is just a crisis
management stunt crisis management 101
we can see clearly the reason why that
is doing it is to really sure about
advertisers if action speaks louder than
words I would actually challenge Elon
Musk to really re-evaluate and to bring
back the content moderation Department
in full on x and by the way we've asked
the White House we've asked the White
House if they get rid of their ex
accounts like the official accounts and
they said nothing to announce but on
that same day the president did launch a
threads account so you know it's always
worth asking the questions I guess I was
going to add this this is something the
everyday person is just doing themselves
they don't need a coordinated attack to
go through Corporate America to boycott
if you're upset about what Elon Musk is
doing just get off of
X right you take a little personal
responsibility you have your own power
right that what's extraordinary about
that clip beyond what you just saw is
what they didn't talk about if you watch
all seven minutes of the full seg at no
point did ABC News disclose that the
parent company of ABC News is the Walt
Disney Company somehow they didn't
mention that their boss Bob Iger had
suspended his company's ads on Twitter
the conflict of interest that's really
evident there uh never came up somehow
they were too busy telling you to
abandon Twitter at all costs because
it's a quote unquote sewer and for good
measure they're begging the White House
to do the same it goes without saying
that ABC News never once mentions what
uh Media Matters did in order to smear X
as a quote sewer they don't talk about
musk's lawsuit against Media Matters for
for misleading the advertisers on the
platform about this ABC News doesn't
tell Their audience that Media Matters
went to Great Lengths to engineer a
scenario that would put corporate
advertisements near this objectionable
content on their timeline so this is
something that Media Matters uh engineer
this is all this is all invented by them
you're just supposed to take it on faith
that X is somehow the only platform
where you could engineer a scenario like
this even as Instagram's algorithm has
been shown to connect pedophiles with
child pornography which is something
that by the way you would think would uh
provoke quite a bit more
outrage and uh Advertiser boycotts and
all the rest of it but really it
provoked none of that the October 15th
tax deadline has come and gone I know
many of you might be dreading the stress
of filing your taxes filing your taxes
can be a long excruciating process but
if you fail to file you'll start to pile
penalties on top of your tax debt and
that's why you got to check out tax
Network USA the team at tax Network USA
has a track record of success they've
reduced tax debt for numerous clients
totaling over a billion dollars whether
you're looking at $110,000 or a million
dollar tax debt they can help you with a
settlement doesn't matter if you haven't
filed in one year five years even a
Whole Decade tax Network USA is equipped
to secure the best settlement for you
the expert attorneys and tax
professionals at tax Network USA can
help resolve all tax cases no matter how
they started don't let tax debt control
your life any longer take the first step
toward resolving your tax ta issues by
visiting tax Network usa.com Walsh
that's tax Network
usa.com Walsh today are you a few years
or decades out of school and wondering
what the heck did I even learn what was
the point you might even be thinking I
don't have the time to learn something
new well if that's you you're not alone
and it's not too late Hillsdale College
is offering more than 40 free online
courses right now you can learn about
the works of CS Lewis the rise and fall
of the Roman Empire uh or the history of
the ancient Christian church with
Hillsdale colleges online courses if
you're not sure where to start check out
American citizenship and its decline
with Victor Davis Hansen in this eight
lecture course Victor explores the
history of citizenship in the west and
the threats that it faces today threats
like the erosion of the middle class The
Disappearance of our borders the growth
of an unaccountable deep State and the
rise of globalist organizations the
course is self-paced so that you can
start whenever and wherever you want
start your free course of American
citizenship and it's decline with Victor
Davis Hansen today go to hillsdale.edu
Walsh to enroll there's no cost it's
easy to get started that's hillsdale.edu
Wales to enroll hillsdale.edu
Walsh now what you can gather from the
sheer dishonesty of the clips I've
showed and many more like them is that
the corporate news media understands for
good reason that musk's criticism of
Mega corporations is also an attack on
them in some cases that's because these
media companies are directly owned by
the corporations that musk is attacking
and other case it's because these media
companies are completely beholden to
these corporations for their own
advertising
dollars that's why what musk said at the
dealbook summit was uh was important it
wasn't just a cathartic declaration of
war against corporate sensors it also
exposed many of these so-called
journalists and news organizations that
are completely beholden to these
censors which is why they're telling you
not to trust Elon Musk anymore because
you know he was mean to Bob Iger
meanwhile they're running endless
advertisements for big Pharma get
despite that you're supposed to trust
them when they report on OIC or on the
10th version of the co booster you're
also supposed to blindly trust their
experts on disinformation whom they've
hired directly from the FBI and the CIA
these are people who have lied to your
face for years about everything from
Russia gate to the pandemic and
everything in between and now they're
trying to destroy Elon Musk for one
tweet out of tens of thousands of tweets
that uh he clarified almost immediately
and he also apologized at the dealbook
Sumit for uh for his remarks being
poorly worded not that these people care
about that not that he owed any kind of
apology at all in fact if there any if
there's any real issues with anything
that Elon Musk said at the summit it's
that he apologized which he shouldn't
have
done but the truth is they were never
upset about what Elon Musk said about
the ADL and other left-wing groups like
it they're not even really pretending
he's anti-semitic anymore they seem to
recognize that um you know that would be
an odd charge to make after Israel's
primee Minister rolled out the welcome
mat for Elon Musk the other day so now
they're back to old-fashioned Mafia
tactics they're not hiding the fact that
they despise him for exposing how
Corporate control of the media works
that's why they're smearing him as
someone who's U going to steal your
credit card it's why they're smirking
about some random mayor in Europe
leaving X as if that matters their
tactics are desperate and also
obvious now a little while ago I told
you that I'd play some more of Elon
musk's remarks and this is the part of
his comments that didn't get as much
play on social media but it's just as
important as what he told Bob Iger and
the other advertisers watch I mean if
the company fails because of an ad
advertised boycott it will fail because
of an advertised boycott and that will
be what bankrupted the company and
that's what all everybody on Earth will
know what do you think then of the this
goes back to the idea trust though be
gone and it'll be gone because of an
advertised
boycott but but you recognize that some
of those people are going to say that
they didn't feel comfortable on the
platform and I I wonder I just wonder
and ask you and think about that for a
second tell to the judge but the but the
judge is going to be the judge is the
public and you think that the public is
going to say that that Disney is making
a
mistake yes and they're going to boycott
Disney they already are well they're
there are some that are for for for lots
of different reasons but you think that
this is going to that you have the this
goes to actually the interesting of a p
of of power and leverage let the chips
fall where they
may let the chips fall where they may
well it's not a moment that the major
media Outlets are going to play on Loop
they're going to fixate on the big F
bomb and try to portray Elon Musk as
some kind of unhinged lunatic but this
part of musk's conversation with sorin
was just as important if not more
important than uh what he told Bob Iger
Disney does not create anything of value
in fact they create negative value more
people than ever recognize that now at
the very same dealbook Summit where musk
spoke Bob Iger uh made that very clear
as if to prove that point here's a
here's a CNN Headline summarizing what
Iger said quote Disney CEO Bob Iger says
number one priority is turning around
Marvel acknowledges too many sequels
after box office misses so that's
Disney's top priority they're going to
work on cranking out more Marvel movies
flooded with left-wing propaganda that
nobody's going to watch they're not
attempting to launch rocket ships to
Mars like Elon Musk is they're entirely
focused on uh Marvel films and putting
as much gay propaganda in children's
content as they can and people are
rejecting it movies are bombing Disney
plus recently lost more than 10 million
subscribers by contrast here's what Elon
Musk has been doing watch and and and
tells us has gotten to where it's gotten
with no advertising at
all I understand that Tesla currently
sells two twice as much uh in terms of
electric vehicles as the rest of
electric car vles in United States
combined Tesla has done more just help
the environment then uh all other
companies
combined would be fair to say that
therefore as a leader of the company
I've done more for the environment than
everyone any single human on earth how
do you feel about that
no feel about that yeah no I'm I'm
asking you personally how you feel about
that because this goes we were talking
about power and influence and I'm saying
I'm saying what what I care about is the
the reality of goodness not the
perception of it and what I see all over
the place is people who care about
looking good while doing
evil
them
okay and he's he's right about that even
by the left's own logic I mean this he's
done more to save the planet than any
other person that's that's hard to
dispute and given that these people
would say that climate change is like
the number one issue in the world and
the the fate of the world hangs in the
balance if they really believe that then
you would think that they would say you
know it doesn't matter what Elon Musk
says or what he tweets he's saving the
planet we should all support him support
everything he
does none of Elon Musk critics have an
answer to that he's accomplished things
that help Humanity again even by their
own logic they're not doing that they're
the exact opposite and these are the
people that Elon Musk can't stand um
they're the people we uh that we also
should not
tolerate what must did yesterday was to
declare war against the executives
responsible for debasing our culture
Force feeding us a stream of lobotomized
garbage while they play the role of
censor he made the the simple and
obvious point that a CEO who's fixated
on Marvel movies should not be in charge
of free speech in this country and
entainment executive shouldn't be
telling everyone else what hate speech
is or demanding uh
censorship no corporate CEO should have
that power they should be worried about
their own products that's it they
shouldn't spend a second thinking about
what you can say online this is not
their role at all but for a very long
time now CEOs have had that kind of
power to censor you they simply apply
pressure to Media organizations and
social media companies and they get what
they want they use coercion and
blackmail to effectively destroy the
First Amendment and they can always
claim that it has nothing to do with the
First Amendment because these are
private companies imposing these uh
Speech restrictions you know on their
own platforms or with their own money
but the truth is that the distinction
between the corporate world and the
government has become increasingly
irrelevant the Democrats use
corporations to impose speech
restrictions that they could not impose
legislatively that's the way this works
but Elon Musk has challenged the whole
regime as explicitly as he possibly
could and now as he said the chips will
fall where they may if people don't want
free speech if they want the the Marvel
guy to tell them what to think then Free
Speech will die Twitter will collapse
shortly afterward uh your ability to say
what you think on the internet will go
away as
well now this is preventable but it
takes some work it takes people standing
up and saying what they know is true
regardless of the personal cost they
might face and that's been happening
more and more it's happened with the
gender debate it's happened with uh
Target and budlight uh it's happened
with affirmative action which is now
broadly unpopular in this country it's
happened with Ukraine funding and all
kinds of issues and now as Elon mus said
people need to turn on these corporate
sensors who have silenced them for so
long these companies need to suffer real
consequences for what they are trying to
do and for that to
happen Americans need to do what Elon
Musk did last night and tell all these
would be Lords in no uncertain terms
that they need to go f
themselves hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there